while returning now to our top story the
fighting in Sudan a violence also
continues in West Darfur a region
already affected by ethnic conflict the
Army and the rapid support forces have
been fighting around the city of
Argentina well let's bring in Ahmed KOJA
he's a human rights Monitor and a
journalist based in Darfur he joins us
now live from aniala Ahmed let's start
with what the situation is like there on
the ground right now we're hearing
reports of just complete chaos and
extreme violence over the last few days
yeah thank you so much for having me uh
our situations Indiana
South Dakota state is a plane down there
is no much to Empire because of the
local
initiatives
ceasefires local initiatives lived by
the community leaders and some religious
leaders have been leading a very serious
negotiation between the Dennis Army
courses leaders and private support
courses leaders where they have agreed
that the stocks gun fired inside the
cities and to protect the civilians
as well in Northern therefore there is a
ceasefires committee lead by the
governor of that that's Northern Air
Force States uh nimirs have been
successful uh stopped the war between
public support forces and Sudanese army
forces uh at least one week today there
is no any
very serious incident that where they
have deported in southern foreign
just who's fighting there because as you
were talking about there are ceasefires
in place you said local ceasefires
between the Army and the rapid support
forces but there are a number a huge
number of other militias and different
groups who are active there especially
I'm exacerbated by ethnic tensions in
some parts can you talk us through how
some of these unresolved issues are now
playing out when we see the fighting
between the rsf and the army
yeah we like right now in southern
foreign there is no very clear fighting
between
especially between rapid support forces
and
uh sudanes Armed Forces but what is
there there is a Miss of
this lack of insecurities there is a
groups of militias
in from northern side of Nyala City and
they have start looting stealing just
before yesterday they have stolen a lot
of hotels where it's located near to the
security intelligence headquarters and
near very close to the Arabic support
forces headquarter this is
the same thing that's going on in
al-fashion many reports comes from
northern airport these militias have
been looting and spinning people's
properties at the same time that last
few days they have not a lot of ngos and
international organizations offices so
Ahmed so I just want to ask what's
driving this because is it that there's
a security vacuum because of the
fighting that's been going on between
the rsf and the army or is there also
something more underlying here
yeah there is something more on the line
because you find that this these
militias who are just
looting people's properties and spinning
they are walking side with our rapid
support courses they are moving around
whereas the area controlled by rskids so
many people they say that this malicious
as Arab and Nomads militias came with
the rsf and under rsf protections they
are stealings and killings are looking
people properties these things it
haven't turned to be like a civil war or
like a tribalism Wars between the
civilians of Nyala and North Darfur no
one from the people from Nyala or North
therefore or even Central therefore have
tried to defeat to to defeat themselves
because they have no guns but things
have difference
the term militias in West Darfur
at 24th this month just five days ago
they have when the time of this war came
and started flashes
at morning seven o'clock on 24th in
Northern in Western therefore algenina
city west of the algenina near
al-jamaric area the same groups like
okay similar groups okay it's not
malicious they are corrupt from
southern side of neighborhoods
we do know that the tensions there are
are ongoing and of course the rsf was
born out of the janjaweed militias who
were very active there in the Darfur
area I'm afraid we'll leave it there for
now but thank you very much Ahmed KOJA
they're a human rights Monitor and
journalists speaking to us from Manila
thank you Anand